[Musik]
[Applaus]
dieser platz im berner
breitenrainquartier muss weg
[Musik]
gar nicht
ja ist denn heut im weg stand
[Musik]
welchen weg sie verstarb früheren also
verbrauchsstelle naturen der kreativ und
ja wir halt eine fünfte kunde machen und
ich bin glücklich und das ist das
problem ist stets alleine retten mit der
immer heißeren sind jetzt die chance
nach bis sechs grad wärmer als im land
ich bin verdammt
[Musik]
katrin marina ist gärtnerin und wohnt
zusammen mit 18 anderen in diesem wege
haus sie hat das projekt initiiert und
setzt es um die stadt steuert 7500
franken preisgeld bei
[Musik]
dass man überhaupt mitgemacht hätten
diskussionen wie pflegt man gern noch
seinen platz im erlaubten ja nicht als
10.000 ppm glaube ich alles
ein paar ihrer wg genossen waren zuerst
gar nicht begeistert
wir hier immer viel shantys und runden
tische sind ja alt umwelt zum beispiel
basketball nominell bekräftigt sie aber
irgendwie ja
und mittlerweile hat kathrin alle wg
bewohner an bord ich glaube doch es ist
ja generell biathleten warten im tutti
höhere die sachen zu holen
sie hofft hans fest
[Musik]
60 prozent aller böden in den
siedlungsgebieten sind mit teer
versiegelt und jedes jahr kommen neue
siedlungsflächen hinzu
[Musik]
pro sekunde geht in der schweiz fast ein
quadratmeter naturfläche verloren in
dieser siedlung in meisterschwanden
bewohnt familie küffner seit drei jahren
eine dachwohnung und da heißt es die
große große fläche gegeben trotzdem
begrünt ist ungestört von mensch und
katze das viertel hätte das gebiet uns
wenig stört werden also vielleicht
idealen sich noch die upgrade ist noch
interessanter wird maria küchler und
ihre tochter katharina haben bei der
gemeinde nachgefragt aber max liebe klub
reagiert mit wenig hoffnung also rettet
st dass dieser mörder sein ziel sei dass
sie das sehr denn interessant ist auch
sehr gut findet michael bonus konzept
bach und sicherheitstechnologie mit dem
hauseigentümer und sie durch ein logo
das die gemeinde auto
nächste woche müssen sie das konzept
abgeben und aus dem feld es geht stück
für viele vögel interessant sind also
zum beispiel vogelbeerbaum daher darf
nicht bei der 67
es ist auch einfach drauflos wie
wertvoll sind für bienen insekten
katharina will biologin werden und strom
hilfe kommt von landschaftsgärtner
dominik smokie
er hat sich mit seinem betrieb auf
biodiversität spezialisiert
glücken
für mich
es wird das fleisch ist sehe ich mich
sehr gut die voraussetzungen und man da
schon ein benutzer die eintönige pflanze
also mit wind behindert zum beispiel
jetzt nicht gerade den favoriten aber
sicher kurz von dem mann thomas hofbauer
machen dann könnte man machen wir so ein
hügel machen dann wollen wir aber
einfach nur das für die vegetation
zurück wochen wird das der ja ab und zu
als dieses plötzlich sie aber es sind
nicht dicht werden und dass sie sich
optimal für wildbienen knapp 47 prozent
vor der wildbienenarten ist im boden
drin und mit dem hammer der wildbienen
am besten aufs tor
hochgerechnet hätte es auf den dächern
in der schweiz 30 bis 50
quadratkilometer fläche die man besser
begrünen könnte
damit geradezu ökologischen nicht allzu
weit von also aber viel größer als die
super aber für den sektor hält die
geplanten veränderungen werden etwas
kosten
je nach pflanze zwischen 22 pflanzen pro
quadratmeter war die 600 quadratmeter
hand sind es pflanzen als pflanzliche
stadt um die sibe franken also da hat
man schon einiges zusammen darum ist uns
sehr witziger stattfinden
aber ich würde ich glaube initial
pflanze gemacht
wenn die pflanzen das doppelt bitter für
sein können dass nachschub ist mit der
aok und das hilft sicher total rechnet
schmucki mit kosten von mehreren
zehntausend franken in den letzten 35
jahren hat die siedlungsfläche in der
schweiz um 25 prozent zugenommen
auch regionen wie das saarland wurden
stark zugebaut
landschaftsgärtner edwin becker geht für
mehr biodiversität unkonventionelle wege
[Musik]
und ich einfach der natur frei laufen
natürlich komisch angeguckt wurde von
einem gärtner und und gar nicht machen
der bauernsohn hat dieses stück land
gekauft und darauf alte obstsorten
angepflanzt mainz jetzt zwei jahre
eigentlich gar nicht respektive auch der
begriff für nötig jetzt mit einer
brombeere wo man ein rechter druck
gehabt im moment und auch in belgrad
genau passiert oder pflanzen heraus
breite mix bruni statischen aber extrem
überhand genommen hat
problematisch sind die sorten aromatisch
und im regal 102
in der region fördern wo das rundum nur
ob kater hat mit hoch stellen und die
hat man somit den 50er bis 80er als
recht lange mittelfeld prämie vom bund
feld und sehr viele genpool sind in der
zeit bis jetzt auf lehrgang wo heute
eine biologische landbau sie agieren
würde
jetzt läuft es wieder umgekehrt die
bepflanzung mit hochstämmen wird
subventioniert aber es wird 15 jahre
dauern bis man voll erträge hat
im auftrag der stadt sagans gestaltet
edwin becker den außenbereich eines
kindergartens um dafür hat er einen
magerwiesen bereich definiert
biodiversität funktioniert nur wenn der
boden nicht zu viel humus hat die zeit
jetzt hauptsächlich brüdern alleine
größe und lage des spontan bewuchs
progress aber viel bestand dass das geht
und würde gerne noch hinein wenn nötiges
paar wenige größe 30 bringen mir sehr
einfach rufe wichtig ist dass man mal
von unten an der eröffnung vor zwei
monaten sah es noch anders aus das ziel
von stadtpräsident york tanna sagan soll
die bio diverseste stadt der schweiz
werden vorreiterrolle spielen sprich
mehr wenn am schluss auch andere
gemeinde vielleicht aber an die kantone
und der bund könne mit dem projekt
motivieren dass sie die gleich
partyfreund wie mir auf doch sind
diverse flächen beruf abbildet mit
vlexplan hin leid wenn man dann aber
könnte die erste strategie umsetzen
gesetzt mit den kindern nur einheimische
sträucher 1
die verschiedensten insekten futter
bieten sollen
[Musik]
doch ein trainer muss heute produzieren
vielleicht auch ein extremer abteilung
mit nur die heimischen uci
amoled-display arabica sie es gibt es
natürliche person finder seite gern
daran dass es gerade im kanton st gallen
grenzabstand von damals gebaut immer
nach das laub weg zur nach gebäude aber
danach als ganzes leben damit zu irgend
wo muss man beginnen findet johanna der
kindergarten sei ein guter anfang mit
denen die börse das modell sorgt
dividende und auch zum überlegte bringe
ja was kann man eine büste ein macher
und klingt mit die bezüge ich glaube das
ist ein prozess um richtig rechnen dort
oder oder deutschland dort und das
landgericht sah ganz bietet seinen
einwohnern auch die möglichkeit
fremdländische sträucher gratis gegen
einheimische einzutauschen
und auf dem schloss flügel setzt die
gemeinde gegen invasive neophyten
neuerdings geißlein auch in der
landwirtschaft ist sensibilisierung
wichtig wiese ist nicht gleich wie sie
vielerorts ist die artenvielfalt massiv
zurückgegangen der wwf hat einen
wettbewerb lanciert um die schönsten
magerwiesen im kanton zürich zu
prämieren
[Applaus]
jede dritte tier und pflanzenart ist
bedroht die hand nehme unendlich viel
zeit zu untersagte potenzial momentane
hand zu erhalten
vor 100 jahren konnten sich nur mit
musik wie sie geht sind es 450 21
prozent von den flächen sind dramatisch
[Musik]
wie schön oder die offene gebote stelle
wichtiger als 1000 die sich jetzt und
dann der buchstabe blossey duisburg
mozzarella ich ganz zuversichtlich
gefeiert wurde von einem gang nicht
wirklich im organismus so schön der
stufe drei straßen sind glatt wenig
biomasse aber viel biodiversität
[Musik]
die jury findet nicht nur erfreuliches
auf den drei wiesen die sie an diesem
tag bewerten muss das einjährige
berufskolleg probleme mit ausschnitt aus
passieren würde so verblödet gibt es
dennoch das 345 trieb unter und wird
innerhalb der nächsten zwei wochen werde
sich grausam also ich würde ihn und
seine klasse und den machen
invasive neophyten verbreiten sich seit
ein paar jahren rasant darum ist es
wichtig dass die bauern solcher natur
wiesen pflegen
die eltern etwas mit dem man sich für
mich nicht er unglück tief
martin mag bekommt pro hektare circa
3000 franken
insgesamt leistet der bund ökologische
ausgleichzahlungen von jährlich 400
millionen franken nun mit den
ökologischen ausgleichsflächen hamadi
enthalten
bis jetzt hat der bund das ziel für 2020
noch nicht erreicht statt 17 prozent bio
diverser förder fläche wie international
verlangt gibt es im moment in der
schweiz erst 12,5 prozent
relativ schmale schlag die blätter
trotzdem schöne bestand von dr
die daten wiesen schon gedanken dass man
die auch ein buch für direkte könige
künftig weiter möglich neue wesen mit
regionalen saatgut begrünen und jetzt
müssen wo die besten flaschen sind von
10.000 bewerteten tier und pflanzenarten
in der schweiz sind 35 prozent bedroht
das ist deutlich mehr als in den anderen
europäischen ländern und liegt unter
anderem auch an der industriellen
saatgutproduktion auf vielen wiesen
wächst heute das gleiche direkt
begrünungen mit solch guten regionalem
und biodiversität gut könnten das
korrigieren
[Musik]
hüfners sind gespannt ob die gemeinde
ihr dachbegrünung projekt finanziert
[Musik]
man muss schon etwas diskutiert es
braucht immer gab zu dem projekt stand
man sich ständig von dem geld möchte man
ein spiel anders finanzieren
dass er nachher umgesetzt haben noch
antun kaufen oder machen urlaub ist zu
tragen und internet sowie tropische land
erkannt dass man selber bestäuber also
darf man in der schweiz niederlage aber
30000 franken darf es kosten
aber man gewinnt dafür auch ein gewisses
know-how
für die biodiversität wenig viel honig
und darüber wieder eine frau wenn du es
vielleicht oder lied hätten oder zahl
und natürlich mit der initianten loser
und gemeint wäre natürlich dass wir
eigentlich würde er gestellt
nicht alle beim bauamt sind jetzt schon
begeistert vom projekt
ich sage da muss fruchte doch am
rettershof monate und überzogen wer mit
ergab ist positiv der operation und
regte zu standort menschen gegen den
unglaublichen blu-ray sehr wichtig oder
erstellen wie im namen so im schnitt
geworden weil man da vielleicht auch mal
seit längerem schon besteht kann man
über eine untergruppe teile dass sich
diese hat auch ein etablieren
erleichterung der interessierte also das
ziel ist es muss gar nicht begeistert
weil die pflanzenauswahl wieder so
gesetzt dass die trockenheit verlieh das
ziel ist es noch gar nicht was
[Musik]
im herbst die landschaftsgärtner
schmucke mit der ersten bepflanzung
beginnen dass die kollegen luca was da
was macht die mache und was die iren zu
machen
[Musik]
nachher ist busfahren muss mit der ta
ist weg aber es gab eine unliebsame
überraschung
endlich kommt eh ich deutlich hören
jetzt nicht genau weiß wie viel das haus
stark belastet muss sondern hört dieses
anderen sorgt werden rund 5000 franken
kostet die sonder entsorgung
das nervt aber kathrin versteht
umgekehrt auch nicht warum die leute
immer meinen außenraum pflege sei gratis
[Musik]
das geerbte sind unglaublich wichtig
sind
was meinen sie für die meisten bietet
sich auf ihren balkon und die die karte
offensive besser als jeder dritte
genormte platten gibt es nur dort wo es
nötig ist
reaktion nicht gut war passiert es mir
das selber machen
viele frauen haben schafft für sind es
tut mir gut ich werde da sein gemischt
platz wieder fahren mit dem kreisblatt
und den heimatsmühle lieber vorm haus
gesungen und pflastersteine geschenkt
aber hoch und die pflastersteine salbung
aufsicht darauf gibt es eigentlich so
schlimm ich natur statt bloß selber
generiert mit meinem material mit
einfachen ich denke halt bei zwei tagen
ist das plötzlich fährt ist in der nähe
von st ganz führt edwin becker eine
baumschule
[Musik]
er lässt den pflanzen raum und greift
nur ein wo es notwendig ist wieder jeder
dialog wo die ihr entsprechend die
person oder war und mit der natur führt
und wenn ich teil ist das spiel für uns
zu sehen im moment bin ich mehr als
schockiert sich mit einem thema oder mit
unserem ursprung auf der erde fast auf
pestizide verzichtet bega ganz am anfang
wollte er ausschließlich auf
inländischen und naturnahen garten
bausätzen trotzdem hat er mit bio
diverser pflanzung weiter gemacht dass
er die verschiedenartigkeit dann dazu
führt dass man praktisch kein schädling
stéphane hand und gletscher rosa heißt
sich im rausch von fehlern ist gar nicht
begeistert und mehr nur zwei beim
busfahrer sind sie sind auf der eben im
sandboden und felder rund um wissen es
in der branche und trainer haben wir
eigentlich gar kein schaden kg und mit
dem porto bedeckt und organischem
auszutragen
hier trennt sich von der unter trennt
sich von einem begleiter wie immer seit
der nützlichen drehen wo er unterschlupf
findet und ein englischer vor ort sind
wenn der negative aspekt geht's los was
für ein schädling auch immer bereits
vorhanden sind und werte mussten die eso
verdacht die kämpfe gegen läuse helfen
marienkäfer aber auch wespen im ganzen
gewächshäuser vor dem spiel sind fällt
rasch mitglied das eigentlich uns nicht
hat jetzt geht marco forner wirkt das
sind relativ friedfertig sieht sondern
auch die bewegung in nashville onkologie
klävers läuft und die türen die sehr
viel schädling gab heute frauen aber
wenn gestandene frau mit lars albert
sich mit protein und im zug
[Musik]
mittlerweile hat es auch im saarland
immer mehr leute die edwin begas ideen
gut finden
caroline beil hat vor einem jahr den
garten ihres einfamilienhauses neu
gestaltet becker hat sie überzeugt viele
verschiedene pflanzen zu setzen
wir sind hungrig
unser war es anderswo der praxis
dominanter will verschwinden die
pflanzen erwiderung damit rund ein ziel
das bildformat lenkrad wie wir zum
forschen
[Musik]
caroline beil wollte vor allem dass es
immer blöd das was gut und was was alles
was man genau die summe hat wurde mit
steht hier zum motto und vorhänge und
sicherlich nicht einfach es ist wirklich
faszinierend was das ist bei uns macht
weniger niedrig gleich begraben seinen
kunden zeigen dass ihre gärten auch ohne
gift schön und pflegeleicht sein können
oftmals so viel chemie die massen wieder
mal planwirtschaft schafft wo produziert
wird der private wenn wir dann mit dem
umgebauten gold also wenn man das
herbizid abwendet würde was sie zu tun
und zu unrecht an bord ist denn du bist
noch höhere dass jeder den weg zur
sicher oder aus insektizid und für das
als quality lütow die rezeptur
hergestellt hat und genau das produkt
auf den markt gebracht haben also wenn
überhaupt sollten es seiner ölreserven
du bist ruf ist damit gehabt die nötige
wirkung hat und nicht mehr in der lage
wirklich gezeigt ja in der schweiz gibt
es rund eine million einfamilienhäuser
mit 200 bis 500 millionen quadratmeter
gartenfläche darum herum
davon könnten mindestens 100 millionen
quadratmeter bio diverser begrünt werden
der riesige airbus ist platz für
pflanzen vorher karin südamerika die wg
hat sich organisiert immer ist jemand da
der hilft ja klar
da verstand vertrieben weil er mit
seiner essen sind wir da die han ina
gerettet gehalten
ich habe einfach zwischen zwar so gut
dass er wieder gelohnt sich neben einer
synagoge blattmasse dass die neue mühle
[Musik]
katrin pflanzt alles ein was noch
einigermaßen lebt am liebsten würde sie
nur einheimische pflanzen nehmen
aber das hat sie nicht ganz geschafft
[Musik]
die guten halt schafft die früchte
werden
[Musik]
damit sollte das bis dahin nicht sehr
viele des lieds
doch es gibt schon pflanzen die sie gar
nie setzen würde er schlafen sind
sowieso immer noch viel zu viel platz
wird sich zum teil auch schuster walther
bus ins tessin sind war das ziemlich
hohl wirkt aber nicht sehr häufig
pflanzen wieder halt immer grün ist und
alle zur gekostet kaum ist gepflanzt
kommen neue bewohner um nest material
zusammen
leider herzlich so etwas schon bis zum
wechsel ja seit auf dem griesplatz
seiten reden
[Musik]
würden wir das mal suchen suchen aber
krippe die baumstämme sind für die
insekten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
katharina kirschner hat in ihrem eigenen
dachgarten ebenfalls ein experiment
laufen sie hat verschiedenes
durcheinander gepflanzt
aber das durcheinander hat system so
funktioniert eine permakultur die
geschaut denn eine pflanze da will ich
dass es so eine flugzeit pflanzen
wohlfühlen so nach außen tragen und
deine hätte den pflanzen da schaute
gespannt über den sommer
ich bin ihr größter sozusagen in summe
also gesorgt
nebst peperoni himbeeren und gurken sind
auch drei millionen gewachsen
[Musik]
welche pflanzen extrem viel wasser
braucht und das problem wollen wir in
zukunft mint löse aktuell steht 50.000
volt weg sofort nadelbäume sind trocken
thematik ist im verfahren zurzeit
passiert überall so holzschnitt und 70
dass man jetzt muss ein mensch war durch
das heißt 1000 ford wieder auf einer
mission mit verschiedenen sorten damit
porto nicht ausgelagert und das wasser
besser gespeichert werden das wasser
konnte nur der ecke sondern flüchtigkeit
von der nacht wird eigenen kunden werden
auf der erde so einmal extrem viel
wasser zur verfügung aus wenn man auf
den worten wo jetzt wirklich immer
weniger wird es für die man schlecht ich
dass man sich um programmiert die ganze
monokulturen werden immer so einfach
sitzung die auf pflanzen will
es braucht einfach viel zu viel wasser
auf dem dach nebenan baut dominic i eine
wasserstelle
[Musik]
das ganze jahr wieder nach leo
modellieren und da drin wer eine pflanze
wachsen und musste dort im renault
setzte sich gegen tierversuche könnt und
diego hat die flüchtigkeit gern hervor
und die uns gerne und lässt sich dann
der breno und zwar natürlich auch
trinkwasser für heißt sie darf das auch
den sektor könnte bis zu trinken
normalerweise nehmen wir auf bedürfnis
für manchen rücksicht nehmen und
besondere fläche dann wirklich mal auf
bedürfnisse der tiere und pflanzen und
drückt sich nicht und das macht er nun
umso mehr spaß zu machen und
entwicklungs beobachter wer sich
letztlich auch wie verbreitet sich immer
wieder über ihren inhalt platz
das sollte selbst funktioniert also vor
durch lina pflanze sind es gab die 750
und für den streik sind meinen hof
verbrauch liegen die flächen deckend
unzählige projekte starten
ein aktuelles projekt baltic mainz wo
man denn die fläche durch die zahl von
nutzer mitzulesen und die erste frage
von sammlern und betrieb
insgesamt knapp knapp 100 arten
kunterbunt gemischt
das ziel des fonds ist ein bisschen blöd
ist also februar bis oktober
seit im oktober blödsinn machen können
die wilde möhre so dick dass auch los
vinos aber wie sie blühte und damit die
in einheit zu dunkel blüten die mit inka
vorwurf der blüte nicht die wilde möhre
forscherteam sowie die heimische thymian
und mitgeteilt dass man möglichst die
heimische pflanzen tier tour das sind
eigentlich die einzige die heimische
wurde oder wie soll ich das ist wohl
birne die berühmte eigentlich als mast
baumaterial dass man sich gott sei dank
die forscherin ab und braucht und auto
wohler knäuel dazu beziehungen zum
nachbarn bienen leisten zwei drittel der
bestäubungsarbeit doch die hälfte der
600 bienenarten in der schweiz ist
bedroht
einzig besteuerung beispiel sind
bestrebt flüge sind gestorben um alle
flüge ob er stach mutter sind bestäuber
aber das müsste man staune das sind alle
nur plagegeister sind habe ich die
akteure im ökosystem
gut
das lassen wir nur eine hand würde ich
da mit dir machen
beste erfahrungen mit pflanzen verteilen
[Musik]
wenn alles eingepflanzt ist müssen sich
die drei erst mal gedulden bis es wieder
wärmer wird
[Musik]
im frühling will dominique den rest
ansehen
der garten umbau in bern ist fertig der
projektleiter von stadtgrün bern der den
wettbewerb begleitet hat lässt sich das
resultat zeigen
der temperatur hatte zwar zeige das ist
gut 45 grad unterschied ausmachen jetzt
für segelboote das spielt natürlich wäre
mit traditionell langsam ab und das sind
nachtaktiv günstiger stattfinden
versichert die fläche für den sticks
potenzial und verdunstet ist frühling
das ist eine stadt klimatisch aspekten
kunden dazu das wasser hier wieder da
und wie kompliziert muss entweder es
gibt massive wo man zeigt das fass hatte
könig extrem effizientes da geht es zum
beispiel berechnungen zeigten dass in
davos 12 grad warm ist ein osterfeuer
gebäude aus beton 45 grad warmes und
hindere begrünte fassade nach hannover
21 grad
alles nur ein tropfen auf den heißen
stein sagen viele
solange die regenwälder brennen nützte
alles nichts
[Musik]
amazon macht oben
aber hier haben aber bis machen
sofortiger wirkung entfalte das ganz gut
machen dann bringt seine biss und glück
dazu die nachbarn sind zur gartenparty
eingeladen
[Applaus]
die kinder machen samen bomben für die
gäste wenn man einmal schaute geortet
kathrin zeigt ihren wege kolleginnen mit
einem selbstgemachten emery was alles
wachsen wird
[Musik]
china ab 29
ich muss ja nicht so viele werke ich
muss einfach das einfachste groß wird
ich habe noch das foul als
frauenversteher
die zügel anemone dank der jako-arena
[Musik]
leiter der it und technik getroffen
würden eigentlich und rechtsstaat wird
sie nachts machen und es wird an der
ecke ziemlich schüler das ist immer das
neue pflanzliche taster weiß sie noch
etwas das ich irgendwo bis heute 18
monate sind vergangen
es ist mai dominik stucki ist
erleichtert dass der trockene frühling
seinen pflanzen auf dem dach in
meisterschwanden nicht geschadet hat
blocher hatte marko hat mir nie etwas
und es ist sehr viel ist durch prächtige
wasser hat nicht viel aber das land wird
eigentlich zum 50 wasserpflanzen oder
drin sind also kurz nicht mehr die
pinkel wunderschön und blühe und die
linie pfützen kapital ich kurz
trinkwasser für vögel und insekten
das ziel erreichte zufrieden auch marian
küffner hat ihr ziel erreicht
[Musik]
diverse us stromnetz gesetz nicht die
bestehende plan zwei drinks in
vereinzelten jetzt die neu gesetzten
pflanzen blühen
ich hoffe zusammen aus zeiten sind
hauptsächlich zweijährige pflanze
königskerze die wird jetzt funktion mit
blüte stand machen macht ein großer und
dann macht ja ich ganz viel langsamer
und die werden dann darüber dem gig dann
sicher jungpflanzen unterstand für die
königskerze wurden abgestorben ist
wirtin auf den sagte braucht alles nicht
hilft über vantrix hilft mobilität noch
blumen an
aber viel ist nicht mehr nötig im
hinteren teil des daches ist klatschen
gewachsen
sich auch wirklich schöne brauch schick
sieht der fonds das design und kamele
die samen in die natur zaubert immer
wieder schmuck wünscht sich dass die
menschen mehr lust und mut bekommen sich
auf diesen zauber einzulassen
[Musik]
die an jedem ort hatten in eigenen
charakter und das bringt da wieder
vielfalt denen ich merke blut hand freut
was sind sie schon sicher wenn ich sage
ich möchte dass sie gestaltet aber wenn
der prozess sofort sind eigentlich sehr
glücklich und fühlt sich aber erfüllt
[Musik]
auch die berner wg ist happy ohne tiere
entsteht ein ganz neues garten gefühllos
resultate lüge der begas berichtet
verfehlen diese lebensqualität brunnen
es ist es ist schön hier zum sie sich
weniger dass weitere gruppe gefühl wann
ihr vorhaben eigentlich kh jedem hof und
ich freue mich dennoch die pflanze da am
himmel steht und jetzt ob sie in diesem
jahr ist so merz weiter gewachsen
drei bis fünf jahre wird es dauern bis
der ganze garten richtig bewachsen ist
[Musik]
es bleibt überall windmarkt auch noch
recht gute zusammenhalt der eyecatcher
ist das begrünte dach
das sind ziemlich viel lüth begeisterten
bleibt starr und trug schon nicht so
viel wasser
[Musik]
bis auf und ab der eine schnecke mit
bravo sich hoffentlich noch immer mehr
ausbreitet dann ist es in der sehr
wichtige zweite versteckte linie
und es mache ich gar nicht mit was sich
entwickelt 20 ich habe praktisch ist der
neue kräutergarten der neue hinterhof
ist also nicht nur schön er ist in
vielerlei hinsicht nützlich und jeden
muss katrin wirklich nur noch
ausnahmsweise
[Musik]